american medical association declares
moratorium on morbidly obese and other
problematic terms
they haven't declared a moratorium and
actually being morbidly obese they're
not actually it seems really frankly
very interested in that it's the terms
and you know this piece goes goes on and
shows more things exactly i have my
screen back thank you um
you know it continues in the standard
now standard woke way of uh not allowing
doctors to use terms that are actually
important and useful in describing
characteristics of people but as we've
talked about several times before here
on darkhorse obesity is one of the
primary comorbidities for covet risk
both for catching it and for bad
outcomes if you do catch it and into
this environment
um
we have we have this the american
medical association
because protecting the feelings of
morbidly obese people is apparently more
important than actually protecting their
health like that that's what they're
doing that's what they are saying you
morbidly obese people we don't
we don't care about you
we're gonna care about your feelings for
the next five minutes but the fact that
you are very likely to die earlier than
you might and to more likely to catch
the disease that everyone is focused on
to the exclusion of everything else in
the world in some cases
that's actually not our job well turns
out no wrong the ama the american
medical association it's your job to
care about people's health not their
feelings at the moment and frankly if
people's feelings are hurt by being told
that being morbidly obese is unhealthy
for them then they need to get their
feelings in order this is insane this is
completely insane
and here's a here's a quote from the
article don't show my screen here zach
but um
words matter said philip alberti phd
founding director of the aamc center for
health justice stated echoing harman's
remarks quote they matter because they
have the power to perpetuate or
dismantle structural racism to empower a
person or to marginalize them to
reinforce a harmful traditional
narrative or to provide an alternative
one
words matter you know what else matters
people's actual health
these freaking doctors and now the ama
are declaring that words are more
important than actual health they have
it's they've gone full
bastardization of post-modernism here
and they've decided that actually their
mission the core mission of doctors the
reason we have health professionals
doesn't matter that's not what they're
doing anymore they are not engaged in
actually caring about people's health
they are engaged in semantic games to
what end to keep their jobs to keep
their funding who knows
who knows but clearly whatever is
causing this it's this is the thing that
is causing people to get sick and to die
yes and it is causing a
all sorts of systems that are
fundamental to the functioning of
society are being disrupted for some
higher purpose that we have not been
told about and one of them is
the doctor-patient relationship the
obligation of medical science to
patients
and something has subordinated that so
your doctor is no longer allowed through
a well-established mechanism to instruct
your pharmacist to dispense a compound
because your doctor thinks it would be
good for you now somebody is deciding to
overrule your doctor
on the basis of
we don't know what with
with a
uh
a one-size-fits-all solution that we
know doesn't work that medical jury has
prescribing privileges except when it
doesn't except when it doesn't right and
you know
this will all not make sense to you as
long as you stay in your lane if you get
out of your lane you will recognize that
something that has not been shared with
us is driving this and it is disrupting
everything including your relationship
with your doctor which has a whole lot
to do with your health and you know if
you didn't want a doctor to be honest
with you you could probably pick a
different doctor but the idea that no
doctor is going to be permitted to share
with you the information i mean look
obesity
has an interaction with vitamin d
right it blocks vitamin d production so
the point is one piece of information
that a doctor who was liberated to say
the truth to you might say is by the way
given your weight you may want to be
extra careful to supplement with vitamin
d because even under optimal
circumstances you would have a hard time
producing enough right that's medical
advice and it's not medical advice
coming from me that's medical advice
coming from the literature right and the
point is it's not actually fat shaming
to try to keep people healthy all right
your doctor i mean you know
because you're a smoker x right like
that is a construction it's not the
doctor's not recommending that you smoke
the doctor is saying because x then
something else and because you're a
woman you're at risk of getting pregnant
if you're sexually active
oh wow are you are you are you pregnancy
shaming me
right
because you are a woman is now even
problematic and so why we're listening
to yeah
i think precisely so i will say you know
there uh
there are a lot of these now but there
is there is one little ray of hope here
uh and i was directed to this on twitter
zac you may show my screen again here is
the florida health
i don't know agency authority something
with their healthier you website and to
optimize your health they recommend
quote
this is a resource for floridian
floridians of all ages to get active go
outside improve nutrition including
vitamin d intake or learn about coven
19.
well i never my goodness create healthy
habits they suggest
small changes in mind focus on one or
two like what you eat or drink get
active
start a walking program aim for a
variety of physical activities every
week
nourish yourself add healthy fats all of
these things
people with healthy eating habits live
longer and are at a lower risk for
serious health problems such as heart
disease type 2 diabetes and obesity this
sounds like basic like really
fundamental nothing surprising here
medical advice that the state of florida
is actually giving to people and one of
the comments
uh in the tweet that um that this came
from
said
florida gives me hope something i never
expected to say
and i you know
i resonate with that i feel like okay
okay florida you you keep going because
you know among other things florida is
actually far enough south and does have
enough sun in the winter that actually
being outside and being active
will likely
allow you to make the vitamin d that you
need you know assuming that you you know
assuming that all of the other factors
are also in your favor
and
it it might just be sufficient
um yeah well it's an interesting
question and it's an interesting week
for that question um as the governor of
florida announced this week that he was
interested in assembling something like
a state militia um which was that oh
this i didn't know instantly the
sentence dismissed by um
the twitterradi as
him wanting a gestapo which i thought
was an amazing
leap um quite a leap yep quite a leap
but in any case there's something
interesting going on and i must say uh
there are a number of topics on which
the
current um blue insanity is revealing
things about arguments on the other side
um you know for one thing i'm having for
the first time in my adult life
serious doubts about uh the idea that
single-payer health care would be a good
idea not because single healthcare
single-payer health care wouldn't be a
good idea under good governance but what
i did not appreciate before was that
under toxic governance it could be
a disaster right um so anyway i
i'm gonna have to do this this is the
point presumably many conservatives have
been yelling about for years well
but again i don't think the
conservatives are right about this it's
not that single-payer is bad it's that
it is contingent on good governance for
it to be positive and it could be deeply
negative in the other circumstances well
so you know almost everything over in
regulations regulation or
you know
mass services is contingent on good
governance and i think that you know
every thinking liberal and yes many of
us are out here um knows that but the
degree to which
good governance um
is actually extraordinarily fragile and
not as present as we thought it was is
the thing i think that um
you and i are still
continue to be surprised by at this
moment yeah which is funny because in
many ways the idea that uh captured
government is the problem that you know
our students were too young to remember
government that functioned at all and so
they have a sense that government is
synonymous with malignant government
this is not a new topic for us but
um but it is interesting to see you know
that all sorts of things like you know i
never thought the idea of well-regulated
militia was going to make sense to me i
always thought that was going to be some
weird anachronism you know that i was
always going to be a little annoyed at
the founding fathers for and you know
turns out no
i'm now understanding that what they
were concerned about was centralized
tyranny
and uh you know it is interesting it is
interesting to see that this
extraordinary moment is revealing
uh
revealing things about previous
arguments that i didn't know
[Music]